mientras los procesos de inoculación en
el mundo siguen siendo un reto para
hacer frente al copy 19 en las últimas
semanas otro problema se presentó en
américa latina' el retraso de la vacuna
rusa sputnik de al menos 9 países en
américa latina' han adquirido esta
vacuna y ahora no pueden completar la
inmunización de su población por la
falta de la segunda dosis argentina el
primer país de la región en utilizarla
sputnik be es el más afectado el
gobierno tras una serie de estudios
decidió combinar la vacunación con
modernas y astrazéneca a fin de
completar la inoculación de su población
agosto es el mes de las segundas dosis
la importancia que tiene completar los
esquemas de vacunación en el barco del
riesgo potencial que genera una
circulación predominante de la variante
delta es que estamos en condiciones de
avanzar en el país en las 24
jurisdicciones para evitar cambiar
diferentes vacunas el fondo ruso de
inversión directa responsable de la
comercialización de la vacuna en el
extranjero prometió resolver los
retrasos en el suministro del elaborado
ruso
el equipo de sputnik ve confirma que
debido al gran aumento en la capacidad
de producción de vacunas los retrasos
temporales en la entrega el segundo
componente se resolverán por completo en
agosto otros países que se han visto
afectados por este retraso han sido
bolivia venezuela y guatemala este
último ha cancelado la mitad de las 16
millones de dosis solicitadas
inicialmente
la vacuna sporting ha sido considerada
el fármaco más económico para hacer
frente al virus con eficacia de 97.6 por
ciento